yo back then um when drugs were like
safe to do like how crazy did the drug
use get like at the peak like Peak D12
days like Was it crazy because like we
always hear about Eminem and like his
issues obviously shots of him he's been
sober for a while it got pretty crazy
yeah I mean [ __ ] we go we don't have fun
but uh
I just remember getting crazy like
at the crazy spot like Amsterdam you
know was it like ecstasy was it Coke
like because that's like back then it
was like Peak like X days right next
days yeah I wouldn't really [ __ ] with
the cocaine Vicodin yeah Vicodin so much
anything we can [ __ ] get your head
Tylenol PM [ __ ]
PM whatever Jesus Robitussin
whatever but no man Amsterdam was that
spot man and shrooms shrooms don't
forget about shrooms yeah shrooms are
still great yeah I didn't cancel the uh
two shows office rooms what happened
I can do it
which were these solo shows were these
detail shows yeah so you just got and
then uh one time uh different shrooms in
St Louis
and uh Marshall uh
see me so that was like five miles away
from the venue and they was coming back
from sound check and they see me walking
on the side of the road
and they stopped me and they said yo
where the [ __ ] is you going they said I
said I was going to join the game
off shrooms so yeah I left the shrooms
alone man
so when you canceled yeah I enjoy
shrooms yeah I got some gummies for if
you want some yeah okay well [ __ ] it I'm
back
[Laughter]
so before you uh but when you when you
when you canceled the shows was it just
because like you were you were having a
pretty serious
was it the emotional moment was it a
trip you know one was shrooms one was
Edibles Edibles are the worst Edibles do
me worser than shrooms of course they do
because they're the devil yeah and
that's how eating weed is the worst [ __ ]
anyone can do yeah if you eat why why
you think that I just think if you eat
too much weed you're [ __ ] yeah like
it's over for you like it's like a
different effect from from smoking it's
totally different so I guess so when you
eat it so there's some compound that
your body breaks it down and like
activates like a psychoactive chemical
that's a lot more stronger than it got
more shrooms with no control yes you
know what I'm saying now when you eat
too much weed man [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
rough
it is like panicking is I've puked I've
like like you said when you eat too much
shrooms
you might trip or you might really like
get into like a wormhole of your
thoughts yeah let's go shut off
somewhere but you you're not like I
don't at least personally me yeah I feel
like I've never been out of control I
feel like on Edibles there have been
times where I felt like I couldn't move
my my legs like I went to a I went to a
I would I wouldn't sleep with a bus stop
one time yeah like I can't move I'm
inaudible right right I had a uh I had
to cancel the show and how I did it the
promoter uh was in the it was in Flint
oh my bad it was in Flint and the
promoter
um was in the lobby
and I called my role manager ola and uh
all of my all the guys that was with me
and we all met in the hallway and I
looked at them and I said yo
I'm not gonna be able to perform tonight
and it was like what they said promoters
in the lobby I said I know man I can't
do this I was like oh pull the car to
the back of the hotel and I'm gonna go
around the [ __ ] stairs so he can't
see me and leave
and everybody was like what the [ __ ] but
my boy oh love he's crazy too so so by
him being crazy he seen it crazy in my
eyes and said
okay cool
and he got me out of there man did you
give this job
no
shout out to my man from flake holler at
me man I'm gonna do a free show for
y'all makeup man how long ago was this
uh about 10 years ago oh yeah well I'm
sure I'm sure he's already took the yell
he's already accepted the L
uck damn man he ran off with the deposit
man out the back door man the shroom I
mean the Edibles did it man the Edibles
are the worst shrooms are cool because
like I think shrooms like if you like
you said that was I shot that King Gordy
did that actually
he told me see he he makes he he uh him
and his partner they they can do that
butter for like two weeks until it looks
like tar
um so and I used like the OG Kush the
power for sure they can use
and um I had took an edible before like
maybe a week before and I and I had
went crazy on his edible so then this
time he said yo these ain't ain't that
strong like that they just regular you
know what I'm saying you good I said you
sure man
say yeah and then after an hour kicked
in and looked at my [ __ ]
I thought you said that they wasn't that
strong and they just busted out laughing
and thought that [ __ ] was so funny like
you [ __ ] idiot the promoter in Flint
didn't think it was funny man
please man please forgive me man
oh my God that [ __ ] is crazy man
um you never cancel the podcast because
he was uh
nah so the highest I ever been in my
life was at a yellow wolf Ritz show oh
my God shout out to roots and I ate um
ate a whole brownie that I did this was
like this was 2014 13. I didn't know I
was supposed to eat though it tastes so
good yeah see a little piece
so it wasn't even like a big big brownie
it was like a like a little square yeah
and so uh I ate it and like an hour goes
by I'm like on Ritz's bus everything's
cool yeah we're chilling and I don't I
don't feel nothing
so he's like yo I'm about to go on stage
so follow my grandma go watch it from
the from the crowd or whatever cool so
as soon as he starts performing it hits
me like a [ __ ] semi truck right
you're right I could not move my legs
damn I felt like I was planted into the
ground
like I've not only that every like have
you ever been so high that you felt like
your senses were heightened yeah yeah
for sure so I'm in this concert
probably 800 people there and I felt
like I could hear everybody
no matter how far they were I could like
hone in on somebody at the bar like 200
feet away from me in the middle of a
concert and hear exactly what they were
saying right and then I look on stage
and next to Ritz's ugly ass is a [ __ ]
cartoon Garfield cat with [ __ ] dollar
signs like slot machines dollar signs
like going and stopping and I'm just I
grab my boy and I'm just like
bro I need you to carry me out to the
backstage
so my my best friend Geo had he like
picked me up like a band I'm mind using
my hometown people know who I am yeah so
I get carry like a baby to the couch on
the side of the stage
bro and like for some reason every time
I heavily do too much when it comes to
shrooms or weed edibles
the [ __ ] that would that would happen to
somebody who's [ __ ] up
happens in front of me like dude this
Native American dude with a whole
[ __ ] headdress like legit and you
know how natives love [ __ ] like Ritz
and Yelawolf and like that you know that
world around I love drinking too yeah
they do God they do shout outs man
um no so this Native American dude I'm
on the curb right outside of the doors
Club Red in Tempe and I'm like hunched
over the curb like I just got him puking
everywhere and this [ __ ] Native
American dude
with feathers
your bootleg cab I look up I said
[ __ ]
wow I look at my boy Geo I said and mind
you
not the best thing to say but I was like
yo is this Indian [ __ ] real
and he was like yeah I'm real what do
you mean I was like bro I'm tripping
balls right now what's up right then the
Indian dude standing here shout out to
Yellow was Road manager at the time his
name is Brooklyn he was a very violent
guy they dragged some [ __ ] dude from
the crowd out they're beating the [ __ ]
out of him like three feet in front of
me I start throwing up while the Indian
guy's there while this guy's getting
beat up it's all happening at the
[ __ ] same time I'm [ __ ] rich is
rich is there laughing smoking a
cigarette it's just the worst it was one
of the worst nights of my life
and then I I ate an edible uh two months
ago my new house first time I had
Edibles in like two years I was like you
know no no no maybe like a year
and I had uh or is there regret bro I'm
curled up on the couch bro my wife and
her friend are upstairs dying because I
am curled up on the couch freaking the
[ __ ] out
I'm trying to find something to put on
TV that'll like put my mind at ease yeah
first I tried Family Guy then I'm like
nah then I just put on like ocean noises
right oh my God he was there and I went
in there I went in the bathroom and
chucked everywhere oh something about
eating too much Edibles always puke oh
you always it's sick I eat up a storm
man
yeah or or that or you'll just be
like when I when I hit dabs that's when
I eat when I like smoking dabs either
Action Bronson smoke me under a [ __ ]
Wiz Khalifa [ __ ] put me a light so
don't do a dad with him you're happy
he's gonna intentionally try to get you
out that's what Action Bronson did early
dab days too oh so this was like before
everyone knew about dabbing like that he
was like oh you haven't dabbed yeah he's
like so he gives me one he's like no no
you gotta take a big hit it's not that
serious take a big hit so I took a big
hit that's exactly we'll have a week
leave it there to be [ __ ] terrible
right so he's like no no now you got to
try a flavor I got this whole thing on
film it's great he's like no no now you
got to try a flavor
so I hit it again
three hits in a row I do oh you ain't
doing conjure out of three years but it
was Mac Miller
Action Bronson a chance to wrap her on
tour and that was the one of I was
[ __ ] high out of my brain stem bro
watching Mac Miller on stage bro I was
just like this is I was probably the
third highest I've ever been shout out
to actually Bronson man wow